Thor is back but this time is battling
an evil elf I'm Ron Burgundy thor the
dark world that's right it's darker cuz
that's the secret ingredients at
anything these days just go darker like
a black guy Oh comedy this film is
[ __ ] awesome it's a science fiction
action adventure fantasy film that I
really did enjoy a hell of a lot I liked
it more than the first story I felt the
first door had some things that could
have been more fully develop more
fleshed out and I thought the film made
all those improvements it's just a
completely different vibe than the first
store you know the first one is if
there's a little bit more like Oh Thor
is a fish out of water and this one it's
a lot darker don't get me wrong there's
still a lot of humor in it sometimes it
just feels like it's out of a comedy who
would have thought Thor could be so fun
they should do a sitcom about Thor
moving to the Big Apple as a struggling
actor can we just imagine that for a
second every time a casting director
says no you're not gonna get it just
uses his [ __ ] Hammond I will say
sometimes it does feel like a comedy
script so sometimes the humor seems a
little out of place with the character
but I still found myself cracking up
quite a few times let's get into this by
talking about the title character sore
play by Chris Hemsworth whose brother is
definitely nowhere near as being famous
Liam hesburgh early on in this film we
get to check out this dude's body and
wow I would totally suck this guy's dick
then when he comes I get shocked by
electricity Chris Hemsworth looks cooler
in this film they updated his suit it
brings the charm as always he's just a
total badass seeing the first floor he
was only Thor for like 10 minutes or
something in this film he is Thor the
God of Thunder for the entire film and
we get exactly what we want to see the
god of thunder just kicking a bunch of
ass he's the [ __ ] wonder how big four
shits are owner if you touch it if you
get the power of the god of thunder I
would eat Thor [ __ ] and of course Loki
play by tom hiddleston this character is
always gonna be around there's nothing
they can do to get rid of this bad guy
at first I thought Loki was a homosexual
nothing wrong with that it's just as
little distracting as seeing him as
Thor's gay brother but this is my
favorite portrayal of Loki
yet I like what they did with his
character in this one I don't want to
give away into the surprises because the
trailer does such a good job at teasing
him that's just being another bad guy
but they give him a lot more depth a lot
more character he's also really funny
I'm telling you every character in this
film is a comedian for the reboot of
Thor they should just cast dane cook his
store and louie ck is low-key and
replaced interest elvis character with
wanda sykes he's total badass in this
film man and him in Chris Hemsworth's
chemistry it's the best we've seen yet
they have a lot of fun together I was
impressed with Kenneth Brown House
directing of the First Lord but I
thought the directing in this was a
major improvement the cinematography was
absolutely excellent it does have a much
darker vibe about it I mean after all
this is thor the dark world and it does
feel like a dark world they probably eat
dark chocolate this one has a [ __ ] ton
of action and the action greatly
improved I honestly didn't care much for
the action in the first floor but in
this one it could be chaotic but you can
tell what's going on it all looks very
[ __ ] cool it's just so [ __ ] sweet
to see Thor you know do different trips
with this hammer and just kick some ass
the entire time I really love that we
got to explore other worlds especially
really explore a scart it kind of has
like a Star Wars meets more to the Rings
vibe about it this film's just
absolutely beautiful to look at even
Anthony Hopkins Odin was more
interesting to watch like I keep saying
he has a much darker roll this time
around he becomes a cannibal that's
right Hannibal is gonna be in the next
Avengers movie I could totally see
Hannibal Loki getting along together
they'd be a good gay couple and rene
russo this woman used to be really hot
member her like lethal weapon 3 what
happened to her I mean she's still
pretty but I wouldn't want to put my
penis on but Rene Russo really got a
show like yeah this is Thor's mother I
don't want to give it away but they make
her look cooler I love what they did
with stellan skarsgard not Peter
Sarsgaard know that sleepy [ __ ]
can go kill himself mr. oh he's so tired
that's also my Mark Ruffalo and tobey
maguire impression and I guess David
Schwimmer for friends Rachel he's always
so serious in these films or any film
this guy as in but this time they really
turn them into like more of a comedic
character he's just straight out of a
comedy and I really enjoyed it the
transition made sense he was funny you
get to see his body do and they even
took more advantage of Idris Elba being
just a
badass you get to see more of its powers
more of a skill they just haven't kicked
some [ __ ] ass plus he's the only
black guy in Asgard they had him say the
word dog a lot you gotta learn that he's
from south central is a huge fan of
Chris Tucker Oh black jokes and Natalie
Portman I love Natalie Portman gosh i
want to have her baby natalie portman's
character yes is extremely important in
this film honestly the material didn't
really give her much to do she was kind
of just fair and it was one point where
she you know travels through space with
Thor and in realms and stuff and they
get to a scarred and she's just like
yeah that was sweet let's do it again
there's like no shock no fear she's just
like yeah this is awesome and then she
has some lines that sound like just a
wine a teenage girl friend that just
seems so out of character but [ __ ] it
she's really hot yeah I gotta find a
porn actress who looks like her the
production design was totally sweet like
I said earlier things Star Wars the
visual effects is dynamite I thought the
effects in the first store was it was
okay it seems a little cheesy though and
this one it was perfect darker like
samuel l jackson i even enjoyed the
villain the dark elf don't know his
[ __ ] name but he was cool he's not
the scariest dude not exactly the most
evil guy to take on forward but he's
definitely fun to watch the character
that was really scary was his buff
soldier the other black guy in the film
is funny I was in the theater and then
at one point that character got stabbed
he was fine but then this black guy next
to me was like they always gotta kill
off a brother that's real I actually got
to hear that you only do that [ __ ] in
like a Friday movie and there's this
tiny ass roll like Chris Oh down he is
one of the reasons you should watch this
the 30 seconds of screen time this guy
has totally worth it and the finale is
just totally awesome i won't give it
away but it deals with like different
realms different worlds it is just
[ __ ] sweet really unique really
creative this home I just thought was a
major improvement I love its tone i love
the action i love the humor the
characters were really fun to watch i
liked it more than iron man 3 especially
because it doesn't pull any of that
mandarin [ __ ] let me get straight to
the point here all in all i gotta say
thor the dark world
right alright guys thanks for checking
out my review for a Thor of the dark we
roll bunchy go ahead scroll that column
box below and tell me would you suck
Thor's dick or Loki's dick and if i go
into follow me on twitter you click the
link right here that's right why are
none of you click in ful see more
in-depth review of Thor the dark world
go in and check out my show called
reasons to see that I do my buddy Jerry
I'm definitely the Thor out of this
friendship and last but not least if you
want to get up then every time one of my
reviews is out go figure this but I'm am
I dig to subscribe that's right click
the dick cuz this God he's ready to
unleash his thunder in a much darker way